ELIZABETH CHOE: End of day 11.
Today was the
rough cut screening
of everyone's projects.
I think that this class really
is more about pre-production
and everything.
And I think that's the thing
that gets a little overlooked
by most people, at
least who are trying
to come from a technical side--
that they view production
as when the camera comes
on, that you just show up
and sit down and do your
interview, and you leave.
And they overlook
how much work it
takes leading up to that
point and of course,
coming afterwards.
And what I was most
pleased about today
was that people's
scripts in these videos
had really come a long way.
It's really funny, because
people-- and I know
I've said this before,
but it's easy to look
at something that
someone else has made
and point out all the flaws.
And it's so hard to be
able to learn from that
and implement that
in your own work.
Some of them are
excellent critics,
and you see their
work, and they're
making the same
mistakes that they're
pointing out with other people.
That's partially
because it's very hard
to execute some of
these things well,
and it's also hard to see
that you're not doing it.
The other thing is when I first
started planning this class,
I was so obsessed with
every day being perfect.
And I would spend hours and
hours just on the presentation.
I think the aesthetic
of the presentation
was really important
to me-- how I
would say things,
how I'd lay them out,
that there would be sort of
this branding in the class.
And today, I feel like
things came together
at the last minute.
And it was OK.
It turned out fine.
For the rough cut
editing we had spent,
I guess it's been
months now, trying
to get this video
annotation software to work.
We were emailing back and
forth with the developers hours
before the class started,
and at the last minute
we were creating
Google spreadsheets
to use those instead.
And it worked out fine.
Doing what's best
for the class and not
using technology
that exists just
for the sake of using them is
something I'm learning to do.
I caught myself in the
editing spreadsheets,
I would say, try this
if you have time.
And I would almost
feel bad bringing stuff
up of what they should
reshoot, but then I
think like, this is
part of the experience.
This is why we gave them
two whole extra days
to do reshoots is
to reshoot things.
And I shouldn't feel bad about
making them do more work.
But it's a fine line that I'm
trying to toe really well,
because I do sympathize with
the demands of being a student
here.
So I'm not really sure if
I'm doing that super well,
and I'm basically relying
on their individual feedback
to get a sense of that.